hi hey everyone good afternoon apologies
for the delay here
um I have a few items to take to relay
at the top and then I'm happy to jump in
and take your questions
um so the Department of Defense
continues to actively address the
incident involving the unauthorized
disclosure of classified documents as
the secretary made clear in his
statement last Thursday dod's highest
priority is the defense of our nation
and our national security and the
department is taking this breach
seriously and continues to work around
the clock to better understand the scope
and scale of these leaks throughout last
week and over the course of the weekend
the secretary and Senior Pentagon
officials continue to convene daily
meetings to examine the scope and scale
of this disclosure as well as ensure
that appropriate mitigation measures are
being taken
in support of this effort the secretary
has formally directed under secretary of
defense for intelligence and Security in
coordination with the Chief Information
officer and the director of
administration and management to lead a
comprehensive review of DOD Security
Programs policies and procedures
within 45 days ins will provide the
secretary with initial findings and
recommendations to improve the
Department's policies and procedures
related to the protection of classified
information
we'll have more to say soon on more
immediate actions that will be taken
that we will be taking we continue to be
in close touch with the White House and
interagency and have also continued to
engage with our partners
and allies
at high levels both within DOD and
throughout the interagency we will also
continue to engage with Congress
again we'd encourage you to be mindful
of how you are reporting and repurposing
these images due to the classified
nature of this information and the
potential impact on National Security as
well as the Safety and Security of our
personnel and those of our allies and
partners
and finally I also want to take a moment
to address something we've seen in press
reports that warrant us relaying the
facts with regard to the U.S military
presence in Ukraine we've publicly
acknowledged previously that there is a
small U.S military footprint in Ukraine
to provide Mission critical support to
the U.S embassy
to be clear there are no U.S combat
troops conducting combat operations in
Ukraine
and while we're not going to go into the
specific disposition of our forces for
opsec reasons their duties include
support to the defense attache office in
support of our security Assistance
programs and end use monitoring as well
as U.S embassy security support
this is not new and again something
we've been transparent about and
publicly uh with with Congress as well
separately earlier today secretary
Austin spoke with Ukraine's Minister of
Defense resnikov during the call both
leaders discussed the security situation
in Ukraine and the secretary looks
forward to the meeting later this week
at the Ukraine defense contact group
also later also later this afternoon
secretary Austin will host the United
Kingdom Secretary of State for defense
Ben Wallace the leaders will discuss the
strength of the U.S UK defense
relationship and our mutual ongoing
efforts to support Ukraine a readout
will be posted later today on
defense.gov
shifting gears a little bit on August
25th 2022 the defend the Secretary of
Defense approved and released the
civilian harm mitigation and response
action plan directing the department to
take immediate actions to create an
architecture and supporting processes to
mitigate civilian harm by optimizing the
efficacy of military operations
today the Department of Defense in
consultation with the secretary of the
army announced Mr Michael McNerney as
the Director of the civilian protection
Center of Excellence Mr McNerney
previously served at the Rand
Corporation as a senior International
and defense researcher and has published
extensively on civilian protection
issues he brings a wealth of experience
and expertise to the role having both
served in the public and private sectors
including more than 15 years with the
U.S government focused on National
Security strategy and development
planning the International Security
sector reform and decision making and
conflict
the director will oversee the efforts to
establish the institution to build on
existing processes and improve the
Department's approach to civilian hard
mitigation and response
the Secretary of Defense and the
secretary of the Army have full
confidence in Mr McNerney to oversee the
stand-up of the civilian protection of
Excellence sorry the stand-up of the
civilian protection center of excellence
and finally a reminder that tomorrow
secretary Austin will travel to Sweden
to meet with his counterpart to discuss
security related topics including
Sweden's planning for NATO a session
from there he will travel to Germany
where he and the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff General milley will host
the Ukraine defense contact group on
Friday at Ramstein Air Base and with
that I'd be happy to take your questions
I'll go to Tara
hi um thanks for doing this so
at this point does the Pentagon have a
better sense of just how many documents
were leaked and the larger scope it
seems like documents continue to surface
in different media reports do you have a
better sense of how wide the damage was
well two things
um first I'll say that this is an
ongoing investigation being led by the
Department of Justice so we are working
Consulting with them on an ongoing basis
but that investigation will reveal more
documents
um that have been you know previously
posted
um and again we're doing our own
internal review assessment as I said in
the top
um this is being led by our intelligence
and security department to get a better
assessment of what exactly what
documents were were disclosed and where
they serviced online
but do you have a kind of a ballpark
assessment of just how many documents
there were and it seems like some of
these documents may have been put out
months ago and predate you know the
window that the secretary was initially
focused on well as the secretary said
you know we're going to continue to find
docs online um I think you're referring
to his comments at the press conference
that he participated in last week I
don't have a specific number for you at
the moment it's something that we're
still reviewing we're still assessing
and when we have a better grasp of just
the scope and scale we'd be happy to
update you but that's something that
we're continuing to assess I guess the
heart of the question is is the Pentagon
concerned that there's still more
documents out there that it doesn't know
about well we're continuing to assess
and that's exactly what our internal
efforts are geared towards and and
looking to review and that's also why
the Department of Justice is also has
launched an investigation to figure out
what exactly is still out there and um
you know also assessing the the impacts
that this has not just on U.S security
interests but on our partners and allies
around the world I'll go ahead to Jen
why is Airman Tashara not being tried in
a military court and could he be later
tried under UCMJ so this is an ongoing
investigation and um in terms of
jurisdiction it's something that we're
working through with the Department of
Justice but right now this is something
that's in doj's hands and we'll keep you
updated as that goes so you're
suggesting that there could still be a
UCMJ trial after the federal trial it's
something that we're again this is an
ongoing investigation it's something
that we are working through with the
Department of Justice but I just don't
have anything to announce on that front
just yet but it's confusing because
someone like Chelsea Manning was TR was
held at Quantico and then tried up at
Fort Meade not in the federal system how
does it work I understand it's ongoing
but how does this work
again we're assessing this we're still
working with the Department of Justice
on this issue right now they are the
lead investigators for um this case this
criminal case
um it's not to say that something
couldn't come back to the Department of
uh defense at at some point but right
now
um in terms of jurisdiction we're just
we're still working through that and I
just don't have anything to announce
today and just to to follow up what can
you tell us about the Navy NCO Sarah
Beals who calls herself Don BOS
diavushka why was she honorably
discharged from the Navy and demoted two
ranks in November in terms of the
specifics on her record I would refer
you to the Navy for those questions but
she was posting
um Pro Kremlin propaganda since 2014 and
she had a TS security clearance was the
department aware that she was posting
that kind of propaganda and was you know
was that under investigation prior to
this classified leaks case yeah and
that's Thanks Jen that's a great
question and something that we're
certainly looking looking into because
this investigation is ongoing I refer
you to the doj for that but is she under
investigation by the military
well she's not she's not a she's a
former service member you can bring her
back on to Duty right now I have nothing
to announce at this point I would refer
you to the Department of Justice thank
you Travis
um thank you I'm just wondering um you
say the investigation is ongoing I'm
wondering if there is an investigation
of t'chara's Supervisors or the other
people who um oversaw him at the
facility where he worked to see if
somebody else may
have been involved in some way in this
and if so is that something the dod is
doing or something doj is doing and can
you say it all how that might work so a
few questions in there
um on the on the first part of the
actual unit itself I'd refer you to the
Air Force for that
um again this is an ongoing
investigation and I I don't mean to
sound like a broken record here but it
is an ongoing investigation and being
led by the Department of Justice right
now so for any questions related to the
investigation I'd also refer you to them
so you're referring me to the Air Force
and whether there's a military
investigation that is ongoing at the
facility that's cool I can't say whether
there's a military I'm not aware of one
at this moment so that's why I'd refer
you to the Air Force okay and um you
said that there's a review ongoing new
review that the secretary had ordered
and just to be clear as part of that
review you'll be looking at who has
access to this type of information that
is the direction of the review that's
part of the review yes who has access to
um who is able to access and review
classified information sensitive
information
and part of that is not just looking
here within the building but are across
our components worldwide so that is
something that our team here is looking
at but also this isn't this is also an
interagency effort um it's not just the
Department of Defense who
has stakes in some of these the
unauthorized disclosures of docs that
were posted online there are other
agencies that were impacted our allies
and partners as well so it is an
interagency effort
great Janie
thank you Sabrina I have a couple of
occasions about the classified
informations released and the secretary
Austin and the South Korean defense
minister Lee jong-sub had a phone call
conversation last week about the leak of
classified document and the boss
ministers agreed that the classified
document was
substantially faulty
what is the evidence that the classified
document is faulted or fake
so I think you're asking about the
validity of some of the documents that
have leaked online
um again I'm not going to speak to
specific documents that are circulating
but what I can say and again is that
we're just we're doing a review of the
documents that's something that our ins
team is
um assessing and reviewing to uh see if
any documents were further manipulated
but I just want to get into the
specificities yeah do you think liquor
has an intention to damage the U.S and
South Korea relations by leaking wire
taping document I wouldn't be able to
speak to uh the intentions of
the individual I would refer you to the
Department of Justice lastly if it is
true that the U.S wild tape it would you
apologize to South Korea again this is
an ongoing review this is a matter
that's been referred to the Department
of Justice as it is a criminal criminal
in nature
we have a very good relationship with
South Korea you've heard us stay from
here from this Podium but again from
secretary Austin as well that our
commitment is Rock Solid and we we have
a positive relationship with South Korea
um just following up on Travis's
question sure slightly different
um not about the investigation but does
the Secretary have faith and confidence
in tashara's chain of command on the
base well I think we certainly have
um confidence in our service members and
our commanders
um in terms of you know the actual unit
itself there's an ongoing investigation
at the Department of Justice we are
doing our own internal review here
um if there are changes that need to be
made from that review that will
certainly inform
um either changes that need to be made
or um you know who has access to what
and when and the interim because his
faith and confidence won't be based on
an investigation but as of today does he
have well we're we're here to pull the
facts and that's what this review will
do and that's what um part of what our
ins team is doing here along with other
departments here in the building is
trying to assess
um what can we do better and what also
was you know happening in that in that
unit itself so I just don't have
anything more to say on this you know on
a separate note there was a statement
today from centcom about a operation
against Isis militants and in the
statement I think it mentioned two
militants were probably killed I'm sort
of curious how you're probably killed
does that mean that they were they
thought they were dead but they're not
sure like probably is a very um
unofficial way of saying right it didn't
say lightly they said sure I'm just
confused you know I'd refer you to
sencom for additional details on on that
front
um but I think in terms of the operation
itself it really does stand as a
testament to
um our commitment to the enduring defeat
of Isis and um I would just leave it at
that just to be sure so are they dead or
no I would have to refer you this income
Oren
two questions uh first am I right in
understanding that you cannot say at
this point that the leak is definitely
contained
I mean it's we're still reviewing it
it's still an ongoing effort here in
this department
um this is a criminal investigation so
again the Department of Justice has the
lead on that so I would refer you to the
Department of Justice and given the
ongoing efforts to to
review and look at who has access to
this kind of information can you give us
a sense of how many people have had
their access restricted based on the
efforts you've taken so far to review
distribution lists and and printing
abilities and that sort of yeah so I
can't give you exact numbers on on
um on like who has had access revoked
but what I can say is that we are
calling through some of our distribution
lists and who has access to
um uh certain information that effort is
going to be ongoing it's not just going
to stop tomorrow and it's not going to
stop after a week this is going to be a
long-term effort
um and so while I can't give you exact
numbers we are taking steps when it
comes to exactly what you said uh when
it comes to distribution less when it
comes to printing access when it comes
to uh just access within Skiffs we have
to make sure that
um
the service members or our civilians
have what they need to be able to do
their job but it also needs to we need
to make sure that it is on a need to
know basis
just to follow up on that I want to see
if you could say anything more about
those efforts when you say you're
calling through distribution lists and
you talk about a need to know it
is that process meant to determine you
know someone who might have had a need
to know at one point and been part of a
distribution list and had access to
things making sure that they still have
that need is that part of the process
can you can you explain that yeah it's
part of I mean it's part of an ongoing
review I mean a very simple example
would be a distribution list that has 10
people on it and one of those people has
less have left the organization but they
moved within the department and still
have that email so it's calling through
some of those lists making sure that uh
people that are sent information
actually
need need to have that information to do
their jobs but part of what this
department is focused on is making sure
that people have the information that
they need to do their job successfully
and be able to defend
our homeland and our interests abroad
can you say whether some of those
efforts are already being made is it
just you're reviewing those distribution
lists or if some actions already been
taken to that end no actions have
already been taken
real oh and then I'll come back to Chris
or do Chris and then Rio there we go
thank you brunette um Airman to share
appeared to hold some racial extremist
views
um and that's been an issue for the
Department that you try to address in
the past so it was part of this effort
um looking at
how you're you can better investigate
find extremism in the ranks so someone
who might be predisposed to do something
like this doesn't release these
documents doesn't
no this effort is solely about uh
looking at how
um or the effort I should say within the
building is looking at how
classified information is accessed and
who has access to that information while
also working with the Department of
Justice in their investigation to
prevent something like this happening in
the future so
someone's possible political extremist
views part of how they might have access
to that or is it just well I don't know
how someone's political abuse and would
shape how they have access to classified
information no again this this effort
that the department has launched is
about looking at our own internal
process on who has access to classified
information and who needs access to that
classified information to be able to do
their jobs it does not have anything to
do with anyone's political dispositions
Rio
I'll come back yeah thank you very much
two questions uh first on the recruit
document that how many RIS on the
partners have the secretary or the
senior DOD officers reached out to uh on
their recruit document so far it's been
ongoing since um last week the secretary
and and I should just say not just the
secretary the chairman senior leaders
within this building have been reaching
out to their counterparts all across the
world I think we read out some of those
just last week I think the secretary
spoke to to that as well today as I
mentioned the secretary speaking to
minister resnikov from Ukraine and he'll
be doing a bilateral meeting uh with the
Minister of Defense from the United
Kingdom later today so this is ongoing
and then you also have to remember that
the secretary leaves tomorrow for travel
to Sweden and for the Ukraine defense
contact group so again he'll be in
person to talk more with allies and
partners
on a different topic that one year ago
the China and strong Ireland concluded
the security arrangement
has has the Pentagon observed any
Chinese military activities concerning
to you around the sermon Island and do
you think that are you confident that
the U.S is doing enough to prevent China
from expanding the military footprint in
the Pacific Island region
um thanks for the question so I think
you said the Solomon Islands right so as
you saw um the U.S recently opened an
embassy in the Solomon Islands and I
think doing so just um renews the uh our
relationship and undermines our strength
and commitment to our bilateral
relations with the people of the Solomon
Islands
um in terms of I think you asked about
concerning PRC activities around the
islands was that right
um so what is particularly concerning
about the prc's activities in the
Pacific is the lack of transparency and
the lack of clarity around the terms it
negotiates it's uh with with host
countries and its intended purpose of
these programs so we want to ensure that
indo-pacific Nations can make decisions
for themselves without being pressured
but for their economic and security
future
um and we want to we are committed in
helping them do just that I'll go to
Lara yeah
thank you um I'm just wondering if this
um the situation with the leaked
documents has prompted DOD to review its
vetting processes at all I mean you have
Airmen Tashara and this former Navy E5
they've clearly have extremist racist
views that they've expressed on social
media including when they were in the
military
um so may should this be part of dod's
vetting process when we're looking at
recruiting people I think that's that's
a great question and thank you for the
question
um we do have a very robust vetting
process when it comes to someone being
able to have a security clearance that
includes an FBI background check and
that includes a vetting of friends
family former co-workers
um and then there is a a more detailed
in depth on just finances
further background checks that the FBI
does but I mean I think we are pretty
confident in how the FBI does conduct
its background checks um when it comes
to somebody being able to obtain a
security clearance and we also ask and
and mandate that our service members or
civilians who do have security
clearances and I include myself in that
um do so with
uh certainly something you know you have
to being able to follow the rules that
are in place which is part of that is a
non-disclosure agreement that we sign as
well when you get access when you have a
security clearance and so while I feel
confident in the background checks that
do go into place for security clearances
and for someone to get access to one
um again that is why we are doing this
process if there is something that we
feel that needs to be added to the
background check process I think that's
what this review will certainly lend
itself to and is there any way for DOD
or I guess it might be the FBI to track
the social media postings of these
people so maybe they didn't Express
extremist views before they went to the
military and and now maybe I mean as see
as it seems happen with this Navy E5
yeah there was an event and then
afterwards she sort of went off on the
deep end maybe is there a way for DOD to
track that it seems like it would be
pertinent
um
so as you know we have to follow uh the
the
I'm trying to find the best way to
phrase it DOD does not spy on its own
U.S citizens
um and we conduct ourselves in the the
uh in adherence with the law
um again background checks certainly do
go through social media postings
um this is exactly what this effort
internally here in the building is
designed to look at
um is there something else that we need
to do to add on to a process when it
comes to a background check and
obtaining a security clearance this is
something that this will look at and
when we have more to follow on that I'd
be happy to update you on that
yes right over here
I probably have time for two or three
more
I have two questions okay great thank
you um my first question um about the
league documents Sabrina how much do you
have a concern that the other part is
like Russia or China could use the
information inside these documents to
harm a U.S military operations or even
their uh the U.S I mean allies
well we're certainly concerned about the
contents of these documents circuit
being circulated on social media which
is why I think at the top
um you know I I address the fact that it
is important when reporting on these
documents that they do contain sensitive
classified information that could
cause irreparable damage
um uh to our allies and partners but
we're also doing an assessment of that
um so yes we are concerned about these
documents we feel that of course Russia
and China could use this to their
advantage
um but we also feel confident in our
Outreach to Partners and allies
um and and working with them as this
continues
the question a different topic regarding
to the classes in Sudan have you um see
the latest reports about data clashes
and do you have any concerns about the
stability of the region and is there any
contact between the dod and their Sudani
counterparts or even the countries in
the area in that area and the region and
what how do you see the situation there
sure so and I I think for some of these
I would refer you to the Department of
State but within Sudan the department of
defense's mission is primarily focused
on providing security to the U.S embassy
um and so while while I can't go into
too much detail
um we have the Department of Defense
through the Marine Corps Embassy
Security Group provides ongoing security
for diplomatic facilities worldwide yeah
I'll go to Courtney and then that'll
have to be our last question
thanks I just want to ask uh just for
clarification on one of the questions
one of your answers to Tara's question
you said that the doj investigation will
reveal more documents that have been
previously posted
so are you saying that the you you think
that the investor or you know that the
investigation there will be more
documents that have not been reported on
have not been made public that will
become that will come out as part of
this investigation
I'm not exactly sure how I phrased that
but what I mean direct quote so doj is
the lead investigator on this topic
um there could be more documents that
are being circulated online that is
something that this investigation is
looking into that's something that the
department is looking into different
media Outlets here in this room have
reported on having different numbers of
pages numbers of documents
um
at each time that you know we are we are
calling through the documents that we
get
um and as we get more that number grows
does that make sense so so you do ex so
I guess I mean one of the big questions
that we all have had here is there's
been this drip drip of of documents like
every day multiple documents per day
being reported on so I guess we're
trying to figure out is is this just
going to continue and and if you guys
have any sense I mean at this point now
that you've arrested someone or the
Department of Justice has arrested
someone
I'm sure they've gone through his
computers his things they must have a
better sense of of what more is still
out there that could potentially
still be released well as you said
they're going through his computers
they're going through his files that
that that they is the Department of
Justice so I'd refer you to that them in
terms of what they're actually pulling
off of anything that they've taken from
his home
um yes we do continue to assess what
other documents are being circulated
online
um as new as news outlets report on them
you know we are also calling through
what we are finding
um and that is that is ongoing so I
think what you're getting at could this
could this count grow I mean we're still
assessing that
um we're still reviewing different posts
that continue to surface online and
working with
um you know we're working with online
social media platforms to get those
documents and and to review them one
from Jennifer's questions I'm still not
clear on Sarah bills I think is her name
yeah the the former Navy so there is at
this point there's no military
investigation looking into any of her
activities while she was in uniform is
that is that correct as far as I'm aware
while she was in uniform there was not
but for more specifics I would refer you
to the Navy but for that right but but
now I mean there's no because like not
even anything to do with the the
investigation into the unauthorized
disclosure of documents anything to do
with that investigation I'm just not
going to speak to more specifics of
who's being spoken to or who's being
interviewed I would refer you to the doj
for that great okay we're gonna have to
wrap up thanks so much guys
[Music]